précis de mais wayne s'appelle police
ouais
à un moment ça peut arriver n'importe
quand dans l'émission la réplique me
débarquer
tout le monde se lève et danse comme
joey starr dans le film voilà même toit
je m'en rappelle plus commune d'ansé
bertrand gros c'est dans ses malles
c'est à dire exactement quand même comme
tu va danser voilà la preuve c'est que
j'adore ça sens où ça aucun soca sont
d'accord c'est ce qui nous fait plaisir
c'est surtout bourse atteint compris le
truc toi bayala on est filmé et donc tu
vois là on va être un peu ridicule quoi
koné lassiné toile
[Musique]
alors après on va danser l'habitat l'air
je préfère mais c'était pas la peine
c'était pas la peine de leur dire
maintenant ouais j'ai été là sans
précédent la con c'est le warm up
[Musique]
on
tom est ce que tu as les fruits sweeney
g des tweets cette semaine beaucoup de
tweets n'hésitez pas à réagir l'émission
hashtag hasselt et déjà la semaine
dernière c'était l'anniversaire de
thierry ardisson aaa et sur twitter ils
n'ont pas manqué de vous le souhaitez
comme morgane n'a qui nous qui vous
souhaite un joyeux anniversaire thierry
merci mort d'anna peut désormais la
photo alors là le problème
c'est encore matthieu delormeau qui a
pris un pseudo ça a baissé les
chandelles
bon on va revenir à quelque chose de
plus sérieux beaucoup de gens ont été
choqués sur le fait qu'on ait invité
farid benyettou l'émir des buttes
chaumont qui a formé les frères kwasi
beaucoup de réactions sur twitter
comme elodie qui nous dit le gars est
responsable de la mort des gars de
charlie il brandit le battre je suis
charlie c'est honteux j'ai envie de
vomir rémy qui dit une interview
intéressante de farid benyettou
dialoguer écouter essayer de comprendre
ce n'est pas excusé hubert qui dit le
problème de salut les terriens n'est pas
d'inviter le mentor des frères krouchi
mais de le faire le jour du funèbres
anniversaire de charlie hebdo et même
laurent était un peu choqués tu as mis
sur twitter très perturbée d'avoir serré
la main du mec qui est à l'origine de la
tuerie de charlie en plus des deux ans
après le drame j'aurais dû partir c'est
à dire 4 yb a beaucoup choqué c'est que
avec ce genre de témoignage tu viens tu
t'assois tu racontes le mec il a fait
comme les hommes politiques il a fait un
tour de table pour nous serrer la main à
tous et moi qui ai beaucoup de répartie
d'habitude j'ai pas eu le réflexe de lui
dire parle d'abord et peut-être je te
serre la main après donc c'est plus un
mois que j'en veux quand je veux et ce
tweet il avait conscience que je me
prendrais des sceaux de merde que j'ai
pris mes l'horreur tu fais des tweets
que tu veux exactement je te remercie de
me le confirmer je te le confirme tout
le monde devient les tweets qui veux toi
aussi guillon aussi moi personnellement
j'ai déjà dit ce que j'en pensais c'est
à dire que je pense que les gens sont
assez adultes pour qu'on leur montre des
gens et qu'ils se fassent leurs idées
changent rien mais pourquoi l'invité
pile le jour anniversaire c'était pas
cool pour les familles de victimes c'est
est perçu comme un affront les familles
des victimes rien est cool et un autre
truc que je voulais demander pourquoi tu
lui a pas demandé à quel est le fric des
ventes de bouquins aux familles des
victimes ou à lui c'est vrai tu n'as tu
as mal fait mon métier je te mets un
blâme
celui-là je le prends
mais bon je n'ai pas à être un censeur
un moralisateur méfiez-vous des
moralisateurs méfiez-vous des cahuzac
qui disent il faut pas planqué large
d'un suisse
[Rires]
c'est énorme
rien
[Musique]
mais de temps
salut les terriens sur canal bienvenue
dans le top 10 samedi soir bonsoir
très drôle nôtre mais je suis désormais
tombée sur dix sont tapés
moreau
prenez antérieures invité ce soir la
femme de défis les plus fous
traverser les océans la ram faire le
tour du monde à contre courant et
soutenir nicolas sarkozy
maud fontenoy
autres terriens invité ce soir l'un des
plus grand sex symbol français celui qui
fait rêver les femmes depuis des années
un corps une présence bref un fantasme
mathieu madénian
[Applaudissements]
c'est patrick bruel
il est sans doute l'un des plus
importants producteurs français il était
hélas débuté avec le françois qui dit il
lui a tout appris tous savent changer
une ampoule jarre louvain
il est l'un des plus grands symboles
français il fait rêver les femmes depuis
des années encore une présence bref un
fantasme
mathieu madénian
c'est une photo truquée j'étais à le
dire c'est pas mon vrai corps il ya du
maquillage et udc honteux de mettre ce
genre juillet pour vendre un livre la
chasse à je m'en vais c'est honteux non
[Applaudissements]
romer ring de wagner à prisme et rhodia
revendeurs
j'aurais bien les basterds
c'est bien parce que j'ai passé ma promo
tu m'as tu m'appeler comment robert non
mais mathieu madénian regarder ce qui
est marqué sur ma loge juste ça voilà
merci voilà comment je m'appelle
maintenant à
c'est une eau ont maintenant les
arméniens c'était jeudi à 20 ans ces
terminaux ayant way justement est ce que
en arménien liant ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire fils d amour
et car deschamps c'est d'abord ce putsch
dans ces langues guitare et puis en p4
guillon 2017 et notarianni samedi soir
les diètes mène grâce à leur zèle
o'keefe et direct line c'est fred volent
dans les airs comme de super héros
l'émission s'appelle sa lutte à la
drogue ou les grandes fortunes et le
hashtag c'est insulter
[Musique]
maintenant messieurs voici mon cdd thème
villa
[Musique]
tout
très beau plateau ce soir va démarrer
évidemment pas l'atout charme de cette
émission gérard louvin bonsoir
oui thierry cocan ça se passait si vous
voulez qu'on ait le csa au cul qu'on
arrête les missions ou la semaine
dernière on a reçu le mec qui a formé
les frères kwasi soit on reçoit le mec
qui a formé le groupe alliage
franchement je vous lis ici la semaine
prochaine on reçoit le mec qui a formé
sur les dinos moi je me bats
vous avez été le directeur artistique de
claude françois voilà cloclo le le
visionnaire mettre des femmes pour
danser avec lui qu'on appelait les
clodettes si on avait mis des hommes on
aurait dit des clodos
d'ailleurs en parlant de claude françois
ya quelques unes de ses chansons qu'on
pouvait plus chanter de nos jours tu as
le téléphone pleure ça deviendrait
l'iphone n'a plus de batterie et puis
surtout aujourd'hui du tu te fais
attaquer pour pédophilie a questionné
des gamins sur leurs habitudes fév elle
est là ta maman
est tout seul chez toi
j'arrive
votre enfant avant soir on ça profil
assez atypique mot navigatrice et femmes
politiques c'est bizarre et en même
temps c'est assez logique parce que - si
vous faites une boulette vous pouvez
vous barrez six mois en mer sans
personne pour trouve ça c'est le gros
avantage alors sept jours avant votre
naissance va vos parents ou embarqués si
je dis pas de bêtises sur une goélette
et ça vous avez fait le tour du monde
pendant 15 ans puis à 15 ans même les
migrants ils ont ils sont plus rapides
franchement non
alors ne vous êtes une des amies nicolas
sarkozy voilà cette passion pour les
rames et
vous auriez pu être autre prochaine
ministres de l'environnement sont mes
proches arkozy avait été bien vous avez
misé sur le mauvais cheval fin connaît
enfin bref c'est
non mais
beau monde c'est une force de la nature
tous les exploits sportifs que vous avez
accompli vraiment bravo ça doit être
très dur pour un homme de
d'impressionner mode en preuve d'amour
qu'est ce que tu veux faire tu as
traversé le pacifique à la rame elle l'a
fait faire le tour du monde elle l'a
fait créé une fondation pour sauver les
océans elle l'a fait
c'est vrai je crois que le seul affront
qu'on pourrait vous faire c'est vous
emmener aquaboulevard
toute cette eau gâcher juste pour que
les enfants fassent pipi c'est vrai que
c'est quand même
le troisième invité il est beau il est
talentueux il se casse la voix c'est pas
macron c'est patrick bruel
patrick qui contrairement à maquereau a
toujours préféré la fille à la mer voilà
qui n'est pas aveugle
[Rires]
patrick bruel acteurs chanteurs il a
tous les talents alors je vous lis
patrick vous avez l'immunité parental
mes parents vous adore à la fin mes
parents vous adore ma mère vous adore et
mon père ferme sa gueule
voilà je sais pas si on vous l'a déjà
dit patrick mais voilà vos concerts
c'est le meilleur endroit pour draguer
toutes les femmes qui assez pour les
célibataires c'est génial quoi c'est
votre et qui est dégoûté c'est lui qui
chante ses autres cliniques s'est pas vu
c'est quand même si vous revenez au
cinéma avec le film un sac de billes
voilà c'est l'histoire de deux frères
qui doit fuir l'occupation et caché leur
judéité pour échapper aux nazis voilà
alors on enchaîne
[Rires]
alors patrick je suis permis g t sur
votre site internet vachement bien la
boutique patrick bruel je vous dirais
vrai par exemple évidemment il ya le jeu
de cartes patrick bruel 1 voilà si on a
envie de jouer au poker il ya la photo
dédicacée de patrick bruel voit la photo
prise au bord de mer en sortie de gastro
visiblement et photos prises sur un
ballon en tanzanie c'est pas vrai oui et
frédéric lopez ou par non
et puis plus surprenant peut acheter
aussi sur le site de patrick le
programme tour 2003 2007 2009 on les a
pas tous vendus il faut bien qu'on les
écoute voilà donc une promotion et puis
pour les plus fous fous voilà vous
pouvez acheter aussi le calendrier
patrick bruel calendrier de l'année 2008
voilà c'est
oui parce que les autres sont écoulés
justement c'est une boutique où c'est le
boncoin.fr parce qu'il commence on
pirelli ou ça tu choisis pour terminer
aux dernières vitesse et mathieu
madénian
battue m'a d'ailleurs humoriste comédien
arménien par son père également par sa
mère voilà une partie de ses origines a
causé un génocide et l'autre on a été
victime à la gueule des repas de noël
chez les madénian a
alors mathieu madénian c'est évidemment
l'un des représentants majeurs de
l'arménie aps alors quand ton pays il
est représenté par mathieu madénian
non le top 3 des arméniens asnav au
kardashian madénian voilà dix ans faudra
vérifier kardashian est vraiment
arménienne parce que moi les arméniennes
que j'ai croisés c'est plus fillon avec
danish morizet connaissent
comment on dit bonsoir en arménien
mathieu aznavour
et alors ce soir on le voit là c'est
l'auteur qui vient nous voir à tarasy
vas-y c'est parfait et ce soir
évidemment vous l'avez vu c'est l'auteur
qui vient nous voir café va tuer vous
venez de sortir votre troisième livre
allez tous vous faire [ __ ] alors on
en vient de préciser c'est le titre du
livre je n'ai pas gilles de la tourette
c'est audacieux comme titre ma fille
avait mis en slogan de son film y aller
parce est une merde voilà manque plus
que bruel nous disent m'écouter pas ça
rend sourd et puis voilà on est bien
alors donc le livre s'appelle allaient
tout faire [ __ ] tout le monde pense
que c'est un ali moi je sais lire entre
les lignes matthieu pense que tu essaies
nous envoyer un message depuis quelques
temps tu as tu joues à deux minutes du
marais et tu viens d'acheter un loft en
tournée il y avait toujours des copains
c'est après le spectacle doit faire
croire tu as des amis à limoges son
iphone et voilà on place la place si tu
as quelque chose à nous dire c'est
maintenant il n'y a pas non
c'est bien ceux d'aurillac
non non non mon pied j'ai beau et murcie
bras
mais bon si la rançon
là sur ces 3
et on passe maintenant à notre grand
l'invité d'honneur de la semaine
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mme actionnait l'union monsois
gravité demeure de la semaine c'est une
forme de consécration non à éviter
d'honneur way apparemment d'enterrement
je pensais pas que ça m'arriverait mais
ladder va t'arriver c'est patrick bruel
le mot
[Applaudissements]
gentil gentil tout à fait un effort il a
mis un costard mais ça je suis écrivain
lalime lancinante a dit me
patrick bruel bonsoir haufor
sex-symbol on l'a dit on va le juste
vérifier un truc dans public ce soir
qu'ils seraient prêts à coucher tout
suisse pour ça avec patrick bruel
[Applaudissements]
cinq modes nom ne sera pas
toi qui adore tenir la barre
un
bijou
alors patrick vous savez que comme vous
jouez au poker tout le monde croit que
vous bluffer quand vous dites que vous
avez 67 ans et vous avez 67 ans j'étais
hyper bien conservés 27 ans avant il
avait perdu se casser la voix maintenant
il a peur disent cassé le col du fémur
alors drôle d'année quand même patrick
georges michael billy paul m schéma
patois michel delpech fini leonard cohen
david bowie prins 2016 année catastrophe
pour les chanteurs ça va vous n'êtes pas
trop fatigué mais on a passé le 4 juin
31 décembre 20h j'avais un peu le vrai
pas de douleur dans bras gauche ça va ça
se passe bien bon d'accord mais je me
renseigne c'est terrible de mourir parce
que évidemment ça fait des royalties
mais on n'en profite pas
et qu'il y avait un temps que je pouvais
pas manger une pizza sur les sur les
champs-elysées c'est arrivé une fois
ouais oui c'est votre nutritionniste qui
vous l'interdît
là une explication
à la bruelmania c'est ça
c'est là
[Musique]
quoi
kinsella fois je serai bientôt
on dit
je te dis comme
je t'aime
alors regard
[Applaudissements]
et pas à long terme
sapin
[Musique]
raté
des rendez vous dans 10
même je l'aimais
[Musique]
mais raconte ans
/
qui a le droit
mais
le droit
il a le droit
versa
un enfant
qui croit
[Musique]
jamais
il a plu
tiéné
activée
va la vie
je tends
ma part sans fil notre histoire qui
défilent je cherche sa main
pour pas tourner la page m
[Musique]
le tourner elle plus pauvres
c'est un champ
m
hambourg
je sais
et comme avant
dans mes rêves
com
ce revenu à
[Musique]
à
humez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'en connaissais aucune
qu'est ce que ça vous fait d'entendre ça
ce qui me fait plaisir c'est de voir à
quel point ces chansons ont traversé les
années et comment chaque concert on est
on les retrouve on retrouve les gens
votre un renouvellement générationnel
lorente à un jeu oui j'ai un jeu sans
risque trop facile pour patrick font
reconnaître ses chansons on va avoir une
photo faut dire le titre de la chanson
un père tri peut pas jouer photo qui
n'était pas tellement facile pour toi
allez on y va à la première
place des grands hommes un point pour
madénian
brion
ils sont forts ces organismes suivants
sont tous deuxième photo kc la voie non
[Rires]
j'ai droit de jouer ou pas ouais mais tu
peux jouer moi qui aimais pas les
arméniens je change totalement
encore plus facile
lisieux regarde moi dans les yeux à
leurs gardes
très tôt jeudi juste un titre
là c'est cadeau
dit rail a déraillé casser la voix bien
bravo
bravo bravo où on fait ça en maison de
retraite
ça te prépares garni
cd je me suis jamais sentie très bien
encore pour toi jardin
pour la vache 500 [ __ ] folle a eu le
doigt cassé
qui a le droit ouais
[Applaudissements]
et notre
cas c'est la voix un avis on l'a entendu
tout à l'heure non mais alors là c'est
ça se passe au à cette académie
bravo
[Applaudissements]
c'est une chanson
exceptionnel que j'ai jamais chez moi
tout seul tout le temps c'est marrant tu
dis ça et qu'on voit ça à prayssas
houleux et la dernière très facile
adieu adieu mais ça passe sur son de
mouassa adieu toute façon c'est pas une
chanson de toi c'est quoi mon amant de
saint-jean pas loin park a
dit qu'on reviendra dessus à
l'exécution non seulement l'idole des
jeunes mais vous commentiez l'actualité
à une heure de grande écoute sur la
première chaîne du pays vous en souvenez
très bien on regarde 80 justifie tout à
fait votre présence dans cette émission
d'ailleurs bien vous l'avais écrite pour
ça s'appelle alors regarde vous dites
sur la télé la neige a envahi l'écran
j'ai vu des hommes qui courent une terre
qui reculent des appels au secours des
enfants qu'on bouscule tu dis que c'est
pas mon rôle de parler de tout ça
qu'avant de prendre la parole il faut
aller là bas tu dis que c'est trop
facile tu dis que ça sert à rien mais
c'est encore plus facile de parler de
rien oui parce que je pense que c'est
le
débat le débat éternel entre eux est ce
qu'un chanteur doit prendre des
positions est ce qu'un artiste doit
prendre des positions doivent doit
parler à jean guillou c'est pas ton rôle
toi tes articles doit chanter moi je dis
aux gens qui me disent ça je dis c'est
parce qu'ils en disent un petit peu
facile de faire ça je dis que c'est
peut-être encore plus facile de rien
dire et sauter danser dans son coin je
pense qu'à partir du moment où on a une
et un homme public d'avoir tout le monde
donne un homme on a on a droit à la
parole sur le monde est un homme public
on se doit d'user de ce droit à la
parole et pas d'en abuser d'où toute
l'ambiguïté 4 quant à la la démagogie
des propos des artistes dans un cas
c'est un événement incroyable
c'était la troisième demande d'anne
sinclair participer à l'émission je
voulais pas/je j'avais évidemment un peu
peur
j'étais très jeune
débarqué j'avais peut-être pas forcément
une légitimité pour aller m'exprimer
mais avec ça il y avait une
une échéance électorale qui arrivait au
mois de mars avec une on annoncé un taux
d'abstention phénoménal qui a évidemment
favorisé la montée de l'extrême droite
et elle m'a demandé de faire cette
émission pour lancer une campagne et
dire aux gens d'aller s'inscrire sur les
listes électorales avant qu'il soit trop
tard et finalement ça avait porté ses
fruits parce que ça avait déclenché une
campagne et c'est vrai qu'avec un taux
de participation plus plus important que
prévu ça vous manque de plus donner
votre avis mais qui vous dit je donne
pas mon avis vous êtes faire pensez quoi
de la résolution de l'onu condamnant la
colonisation de la palestine par israël
j'en pense qu'il ya des années que je
prône que je prends deux états je suis à
l'initiative de la conférence de genève
j'ai toujours essayé de réunir
palestiniens israël ya ensemble sur un
sur un même terrain de mon terrain le
terrain artistique soit des scènes de
spectacles ou des initiatives très
symbolique et il a man je pense que
gouvernement israélien doit faire doit
faire un effort de ce côté là mais mais
est-ce que c'était bien est-ce que
c'était bien raisonnable de la part
d'obama de de faire ce geste avant de
partir je crois pas oui moi je suis
garde espoir qu'un jour ça s'arrange
c'est que ça se passe ça existe dans la
paix et la sécurité c'est la sécurité
d'israël évidemment voir ce soir je ne
reçois pas le patrick bruel chanteur je
ne reçois pas le patrick bruel joueurs
de poker je reçois le patrick bruel
acteur de cinéma vous êtes à la fiche de
1-5 de byd christian duguay avec elsa
zylberstein bernard campan et la
participation de christian clavier et de
kev adams alors le pitch devin
suspicieux du sac de billes dans la
france occupée maurice et joseph deux
jeunes frères juifs tente d'échapper aux
nazis on regarde à quoi ça ressemble
[Musique]
t'es pas passer là ce genre de petits
enclos
tu vois retour tiger tu vas t'en prendre
une
il ya un problème
il faut partir d'ici c'était trop
dangereux l'histoire
vous allez me jurez que jamais
vous direz à cause du lift trois
missions tous
des juifs
contactez louise non societies
haefflinger pas juive
[Musique]
que perdent la vie parce qu'on a peur
d'en prendre
[Musique]
soyez on était parti
un
projet libre on l'avait jamais dit tu es
petit plus des piétons tout tu pue du
cul je t'apporterai jusqu'au bout du
monde s'il le fallait
tout le monde avait peur
même si tous ces troubles
on a fini pour bly ecoiffier quelque
chose
je vais voir
je ne peux pas responsable de cette
fuite il faut regarder devant ana et pas
trop tourner
[Musique]
ouais
ça ne m'intéresse pas on s'en sortira
jamais tu passeras papiers de l'espoir
qui va faire
regardez tenir
si on me le demande
arte visuel on tomberait comme ça tu
t'inscris
un stack de vie en salle 18 janvier avec
patrick bruel qui m'ont invité ce soir
on est gosse
d'orient leclec et baptiste floriales
palmieri son incroyable déjà incroyable
on peut dire ça c'était là moi c'est la
raison pour laquelle j'y suis allé on va
proposer ce film j'ai hésité je me suis
dit bon peut-être un film de plus sur le
sujet j'ai déjà que j'ai déjà fait un
secret
est ce que est ce que finalement j'ai
rencontré christian duguay qui a été
très convaincant d'abord par lang qui
voulait prendre la détermination qu'il
avait l'application qu'il était par
rapport aux sujets et je lui ai dit tout
ça c'est beau mais si t'as pas de gosses
absolument exceptionnelle ça vaut pas le
coup le film tiendra pas la route parce
que ce film c'est le film de ses deux
enfants
il m'a montré les essais sur un ipad je
suis tombé voilà c'est hallucinant et
c'est vrai que c'est extraordinaire pour
des pour des jeunes générations de
connaître le sujet les deux enfants avec
qui on a tourné ne connaissait pas
l'histoire ne savaient pas ce qu'ils ont
classé en 40 il survole au lycée la
guerre 40
il y en a certains qui font l'économie
de ces de cette tragédie et qui la
connaissent pas ce qu'il faut dire aux
gens aussi c'est que quand on ne connaît
pas le passé on ne peut pas appréhender
le présent et encore moins l'avenir et
puis ce qui est formidable c'est c'est
cet homme que j'incarne romane le père
qui est complètement visionnaire
lui il a connu les peaux grande inconnue
les programmes il était obligé de partir
d'urgence avec son père fait pour ça et
ce soir là il y là soit ses enfants à
table on né en 1942 et et il leur dit
c'est ce soir que vous partez ils ont
une demi heure pour prendre un peu
d'argent pour avoir un une petite carte
de france quelques indications quelques
conseils une consigne ne jamais dire
qu'ils sont juifs sous aucun prétexte
vous avez une seule extraordinaire leila
ben ali voilà pour le préparer pour le
préparer à un interrogatoire et puis tu
sais on a tourné ce film dans un moment
assez particulier en attendant d'ici au
20 novembre l'année dernière les scènes
les plus les plus fortes scène de la
claque la scène où je les laisse à
moisson nouvelle à un moment donné ont
été tournés entre le 16 et le 20
novembre était à trois jours après les
attentats ou moi j'ai pris mes deux
enfants dans les bras le 14 novembre ils
étaient dans le stade mais
ils ont eu comme tout le monde peur mais
j'ai été pris dans mes bras pour
rassurer pour expliquer l'inexplicable
et deux jours après j'étais en train
d'expliquer l'inexplicable a deux
enfants 1942 1 je trouvais que ça
résonnait pas mal
alors je n'ai pas fait fortune dans la
flagornerie tout le monde le sait je
trouve formidable dans le fil il ya un
côté yves montand c'est à dire que
j'aimais beaucoup ils se montrent ans
cette capacité à jouer en retenue et à
bicyclette
on aurait pu alors c'est une histoire
vraie dans le héros qui est aussi
l'auteur du best seller dont a été tiré
le le film s'appelle joseph joffo le
réalisateur christian duguay et la
rencontre et vous l'avez rencontré vous
pouvez bien sûr il est il est venu sur
le tournage me dire dès le premier jour
je suis tellement heureux que tu sois
mon père
je dis attend la fin
et quand il est sorti de la projection
il a il a eu des mots des mots très
troublant mais c'est vrai que c'est s
était pas une
c'était pas une pression mais c'était
une mission pour moi j'avais envie
d'être le père qui l'avait aidé à
idéaliser mathieu justement vous dites
dans votre livre site ouais ok
[Musique]
là là c'était un écrivain que je
m'adonne dis le moi je met les lunettes
vous dites dans votre livre les juifs ne
contrôlent pas le monde c'est un truc
ils font croire à leur mère pour qu'elle
soit fière de ses tubes
[Applaudissements]
j'ai mis ce trajet à l'asie alors c'est
un juif il appelle sa mère effet le
moment comment ça va elle y fait très
bien mon chéri a bien excuser moi je me
suis trompé
c'était la perversité
[Musique]
vous
vraiment soirée terrienne nom soit le
cas nous sommes de retour soutient
toujours en compagnie de m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avant les matchs de nos
vies
[Applaudissements]
on passe maintenant à notre thé au top
de la semaine
[Musique]
il
je reçois maintenant un jeune auteur
prometteur il publie aujourd'hui son
premier véritable livre on parle d'ores
et déjà de lui pour les prix notamment
le goncourt du meilleur titre le livre
c'est allez tous vous faire [ __ ]
sait faire sédition en fait quand on
voit le bouquin sera dû être publié chez
fist ça aurait été un raccord alors au
dépeint en fait voulu appeler ce livre
allez tous vous faire [ __ ] fils de
[ __ ] et oui si ça rentrait pas dans le
truck voilà centre et passe à
dépenser alors le pitch allez tous vous
faire [ __ ] vous [ __ ] d'ailleurs
plus de 1000 personnes ont dans ce livre
mathieu madénian sentais lent thierry
ardisson vous dit à mon sujet
thierry ardisson qui s'est lui même
déposé à l'inpi pour gagner du temps oui
c'est vrai d'ailleurs je crois que tu
déposes même l'idée d'avoir des idées en
fait on pour être aussi que je ne ferai
pas un procès pour insulte en fait j'ai
plus d'argent toi si tu peux y aller
bien qu'il a trouvé l'idée de la paix
rien n'a pas deux battants l'écho et
[Rires]
je trompais mathieu d'ailleurs j'ai
vérifié j'ai déposé
allende avait tous vous faire [ __ ]
mairie je vais vous ruiner
le titre vient d'une phase de michel
drucker en fait sûrs le ca sur son
plateau quand ça va pas et ça c'est
quand il est poli alors le sujet de
michel drucker boudin le chien était
mieux payés que moi oui il saigne et
plus autographes
oui il est pas mort c'est toujours le
même j'aimerais sur requiert le nom le
chien
[Musique]
ado
alors petit
le dites dans votre livre il ya des gens
qui pensent à michel drucker pour
retarder leur éjaculation ce que ce que
personnellement je pratique aussi bon
ils vous voient en arrière-plan et oui
automatiquement donc ça
ce que vous n'aimez pas non plus il leur
dit d'aller se faire [ __ ] c'est les
gens qui disent impactées à wayne ses
expressions laboute fontenoy page 21
selon lui c'est vrai ce nom vous dit
impactés vous dites sur la couverture
plus qu'un livre c'est un cri ouais oui
c'est un espace est souvent un oui
[Rires]
surtout la première fois
c'est un moyen de se lâcher quoi en fait
c'est juste ça donc c'est écrit lé
christelle parlanti et stéphane les
numéros exa je salue bien bas parce que
c'est lui qui me rend drôle tous les
samedis soirs c'est un cadeau idéal pour
la saint valentin ou ou les enterrements
way ou les crucifix euros non je pense
quand même vous êtes le premier arménien
à sortir un livre plutôt qu'un tri city
ah oui de vous ce droit là
à
ça c'était un
ça florent là qu'on a entendu j'ai pour
toi arménie ouais c'est ça c'est un
disque on avait fait un sacré soirée
[Applaudissements]
alors y'a rien sur elle ne brille pas le
droit pourtant il vient le spectacle à
ce niveau il est venu il est venu
charles aznavour il est venu avant noël
et jamais le train quand on monte sur
scène et j'ai pu taillage charles
aznavour et je monte sur scène et ça se
passe bien que je reviens dans ma loge
vieira [ __ ] cool ça s'était passé il
arrive il me dit il ya un truc c'est que
j'ai oublié mon appareil auditif rhin
sud j'ai rien entendu mais je vais
revenir une autre
ville tombe fort a l'air marrant
immédiat mathieu est ce qu'il faisait
penser quand même à la honte de vos
parents en voyant le titre de ce livre
alors d'abord j'ai envoyé la photo donc
ces fiers photo et classe et le titre
mais nous même et enfin dans le sud de
la france ont pleinement et chez mes
parents on se parle comme ça je n'ai pas
à perpignan c'est une façon de se dire
bonjour mon père il me dit fils de plus
de force pour faire chez ma mère donc on
peut dire à quel point à quel point il a
des infos que t'as pas où
alors j'espère que michel drucker là
vous invité dans son émission je vois ce
que je rêve de voir autant qu'hier ça en
train dire mathieu madénian vous êtes
ici pour aller bouffer en q1 j'ai fait
ça pour ça bah ouais bah ouais prend
et
rapace à mathieu il ya le spectacle en
état d'urgence qui reprend le 19 janvier
à la polo de paris et qui sera prolongée
aussi longtemps que l'état d'urgence je
prenais donc sa durée 25 ans je jouais
pas mal vous écrivez toujours dans
charlie hebdo oh oui oui oui c'est bien
sûr ça vous trouvez ça commande invités
farid l'émir débute sur moi ce mec ce
mec a pour moi il responsable la mort de
mes amis donc voilà je suis paraître je
serais pas resté mai mais encore une
fois je ne parle pas de charlie hebdo je
parle de mes amis à moi que charb
thynnus avec qui j'ai mes skis et je
suis tjrs a dit un truc sur charlie
c'est que quoi qu'on dise un journal qui
a traversé tellement d'épreuves et il ya
eu plein de gens qui se donnent tous ont
dit je suis charlie et quand ils ont lu
charlie ce lundi mais en fait non je
suis pas charrier du tout et que ce
journal chaque semaine soit édité et que
dans ce journal chaque semaine il ya des
gens qui soient libres d'écrire et de
dessiner ce qu'ils veulent et bien je
vous dis je suis super fier de
participer à ce show là
alors vous faites un carton alors dans
l'émission de thomas thouroude qui
s'appelle actualites y donc fait une
plastie vous apparaissez avec vdb way et
françois hollande adore vous l'a dit et
bien dit attends c'est quand même ce que
françois hollande ilana foot il ya ans
je remette l'après-midi à l'elysée
j'ai entendu dire qu'il aimait bien et
moi j'ai rencontré une fois françois
hollande si on parle de charlie il ya en
locaux de charlie donc il ya on attend
il y avait réussi avec lou et d'un coup
on voit françois hollande arrivé et moi
je ne sais pas dire allez politique je
dis pas bonjour je m'en fous un peu donc
je me pousse un peu et là il ya une
espèce de mouvement de foot je me trouve
emporté face à françois hollande il à un
mètre de moi je me dis [ __ ] merde il
existe en fait et et l'a jeté à terre un
seigneur si vous avez une vache si vous
existez donnez moi une vanne
extraordinaire maintenant et là ils me
reconnaissent pas quoi il dit bonjour
monsieur madénian je vois je fais
bonjour vous êtes
et ici elle plaisanté
[Applaudissements]
alors le figaro figaro et le parisien
adore votre petit on s'amuse bien avec
toi c'est un carton ça marche pas mal
mais bon c'est une plastique on a créé
il ya 2 3 ans chez moi puisque cet homme
habite en face de chez moi et quand ils
venaient prendre le café on mettait
notre iphone on faisait les cons et
france 2 nous a contactés pour faire ça
tous les jours et on s'éclate et c'est
vachement bien regarde à quoi ça
ressemble
aujourd'hui c'est qui pour c'est la fête
du pardon une défaite est plus
importante pour la communauté juive
saluer ce jeu est fait et qu'est ce que
ça lui les juifs oui tu as le droit
autant pour la balle avec le petit
chapeau n'a ainsi pas la kippa ça
s'appellerait français joli petit
chapeau voilà donc bon nous on n'est pas
juif voilà mais on vous pardonne aussi
voilà pour la vérité si je mens numéro 3
voilà tout est pardonné voilà pour
patrick bruel ouais ça veut dire patrick
bonnet tout est pardonné tous tes albums
même l'album tha effet dans les reprises
de vieux là tu es bon ben ça c'est
pardonnez mon gars donné voilà tous les
morceaux mer les faces b tout est
pardonné ses films aussi on pardonne des
films voilà même son film tout est
pardonné
bhl ne serait ce que pour tes chemise
tout est pardonné enfin il met aussi son
film aussi pour son fermier et puis et
puis on vous remercie aussi parce que
quand on a un problème est que c'est pas
votre faute et bien même si c'est pas
votre faute on peut dire que c'est votre
faute
mais c'est
grâce à mon entraîneur il rien d'un truc
qui m'intrigue c'est qu'après le grand
journal de maïtena biraben vous
travaillez à actualitté l'émission de
thomas thouroude et je me demande si
vous n'aviez pas annoncé être humoriste
britannique
ça commence à marcher actually thiel
commencer l'émission quand même donc non
je suis très content il nous laisse
faire ce qu'on veut en fait ça c'est
génial donc je les remercie même là on
n'a pas parlé le cinéma parce qu'on n'a
pas le temps mais c'est vrai qu'il ya
une photo extraordinaire que j'ai
patrick bruel voilà là ou pas je raconte
une histoire vraie les chauffeurs de
taxi parce que moi quand j'ai des rôles
ces chauffeurs de taxi une barman
j'arrive sur le plateau et 6 et on me
dit tu vas jouer avec sophie marceau et
patrick bruel hors jeu sophie marceau
jouera dans le texte que j'ai à dire ces
[ __ ]
et toute la journée j'étais chez moi je
fais quoi [ __ ] t je m'entraînais à
dire ça original je paye pour ce bon et
[Applaudissements]
il arrive j'arrive sur le plateau est là
patrick m'accueille et fausses à mon
truc patrick bruel super sympa sur les
plateaux il me voit il fait beau hélas
tout le monde nous regarde et je fais au
hilal mois effet au bruno
et là dans la vraie vie tu fais non moi
c'est mathieu mais là c'est bruel on
alla bourges fait au patrick et pendant
une journée je me suis rappelé bruno le
maire le meilleur c'est que face aux
redoutables écoute bien c'est que
quelques mois après qui a invité chez
drucker et moi je travaille chez drucker
donc je me suis dit il va s'apercevoir
je m'appelle mathieu il va dire il est
fou ce mec je suis assis là ok mais
drucker et là toi tu arrives bruel de
règles de rigueur s'élève effet patrick
tu connais mathieu bonjour achevée
et là tu vois il fait non on chantait
[ __ ] tu m'avais oublier
ses mémoires
vives
[Applaudissements]
il
allez tous vous faire [ __ ] et 7 mai
chaque jour
on passe maintenant dossier de la
semaine et si le porte parole de jean
luc mélenchon avec 6 corbières que nous
accueillerons sur ce plateau après le
magnéto dossier de ce soir faut-il
limiter le salaire des patrons
[Musique]
en 2015 le salaire moyen des patrons du
cac 40 a augmenté de presque 20% quand
on sait que pendant ce temps là le
salaire moyen des français a augmenté à
peine 2% il ya de quoi s'indigner c'est
que les grands patrons ne mérite même
pas leur augmentation puisqu'en 2015 les
bénéfices des entreprises du cac 40 ont
chuté de 11% et pourtant avec un salaire
moyen de plus de 4 millions d'euros par
an les patrons des plus grandes
entreprises françaises ne sont pas si
bien payé que ça alors bien sûr quand on
voit que chez renault carlos ghosn
touche 750 fois le smic ça fait
polémique mais il faut savoir que nos
pauvres petits pdg du cac 40 sont bien
moins payé que les pdg américains
britanniques ou allemands si les
salaires des grands patrons flambé dans
le monde ces dernières années c'est
claude rémunération est désormais lié au
rendement financier des entreprises sur
les trente dernières années la valeur en
bourse des 500 plus grandes entreprises
américaines avec steam est partie ce
résultat quant à patron baisse les
salaires et supprime les emplois il
améliore la rentabilité de l'entreprise
et les actionnaires n'hésite pas à
l'augmenter évidemment cette logique
économique entraîne des conséquences
politiques ces salaires exorbitants font
régulièrement la une des journaux ce qui
alimente le vote protestataire au fn on
estime que cette injustifiable de gagner
plus d'un million d'euros par an
personne
quant à jean luc mélenchon il promet
qu'un amant d'instaurer un salaire
maximum à 350000 euros il ne faut pas
une échelle plus grande que de 1 à 20 et
encore on est gentil en avant le thème
est porteur puisque 86 % des français
voudrait limiter le salaire des grands
patrons pauvres patrons des grands
footballeurs et les grands artistes eux
aussi gagnent des millions mais leur
talent est accessible au grand public
tandis que les patrons eux sont de plus
le symbole de la montée des inégalités
c'est pourtant injuste d'abord parce que
les patrons du cac 40 ne sont pas
représentatifs des deux millions de
chefs d'entreprises en france et d'autre
part parce que selon l'insee les
inégalités de revenus en france n'ont
pas augmenté depuis 2008 voilà c'est
fait it all blacks au milan l'image d'un
julien gracq
ainsi qu'envers bonsoir vous êtes le
pompage de jean-luc mélenchon
bienvenue parmi nous alors évidemment
nouvelle polémique
carlos ghosn patron de renault qui vient
de toucher une plus value de 6 millions
d'euros en fait la loi anti gones dans
sap 1,2 d'un servi à rien absolument
servi à rien ça fait ce thème il revient
souvent et souvent on répond que
premièrement les patrons il y aura de
l'autorégulation et puis en a même
certains qui théorisent que c'est une
bonne chose que c'est la théorie du
ruissellement
c'est bien qu'ils des gens très riches
parce que ça va profiter aux autres mais
ce qu'on observe c'est que et vous le
savez vous en parlait parfois la
pauvreté en france elles augmentent ils
se trompent blaco le rapport de l'insee
du 5 décembre 2016 est dit clairement
que les inégalités se creusent en france
il ya aujourd'hui 8 8 millions de gens
qui vivent sous le seuil de pauvreté et
on en a 1 millions supplémentaires en
dix ans et à linverse ya ça je vais
donner une date le 3 janvier à 18 heures
mais pour les 120 patrons qui sont les
mieux rémunérés à partir de ce moment là
il avait gagné autant qu'un salarié
français ce qu'il touchera sur toute
l'année à deux jours éditions deux jours
deux jours et 18 heures après ce que
c'est normal donc nous avec jean luc
mélenchon ce qu'on propose c'est pas
d'écarts de salaires supérieurs de
l'entreprise de 1 à 20 si le plus haut
salaire va s'élever il augmente tout le
monde n'est pas ce ya rien qui justifie
que quelqu'un selon moi gagne plus de
cinquante soixante cinq fois plus mais
quelqu'un d'autre vous vous recommander
que le salaire maximum d'un patron soit
de 350000 euros par an voilà qui va tout
revendre seulement tu vas t'en sortir
bellemare dit on la sait pas mais
vous savez que la part reversée aux
actionnaires lors du trimestre 2016 de
l'année dernière a été c'est un record
35 milliard versé aux actionnaires le
problème c'est que tout cet argent ces
richesses produites par les travailleurs
quand elles sont reversés aux
actionnaires elles sont pas investis
dans l'entreprise pour améliorer l'outil
de production et pour mieux payer les
salariés tout cet argent captée par une
poignée sa part souvent dans des paradis
fiscaux faut lire on 60 à 80 milliards
d'euros chaque année d'évasion fiscale
gérard vous accepteriez un fixe
arbitrairement de salaire non alors
c'est un débat on peut parler pendant
des années vous aurez toujours raison
parce que vous avez la majorité avec
vous mais le talent n'a pas le talent
n'a pas de valeur c'est un footballeur
qu'il ya un million alors ces bateaux ce
que je vais dire mais un million par
mois vous trouvez ça normal le dérange
pas non ça ne dérange pas et je vais
prendre un exemple est un chanteur on a
un exemple attendant je vais prendre un
exemple de justement patrick que je
connais depuis 82 g le plus gros
fraudeurs de
hanau en afrique je les ai vus jouer au
théâtre en 84 1 peut pas être maria
pacôme dans une pièce il devait gagner
200 euros de ma poche 100 francs non 200
francs 200 francs par un os que c'est
maintenant il ya une beaucoup d'argent
mais non
canadiens ya des comédiens qui gagne
encore 200 francs bah oui bon et
pourquoi ils gagnent 200 francs et que
lui gagnent beaucoup d'argent parce
qu'il a plus de talent que ses comédiens
je pense qu'il devrait améliorer
monsieur y avait et si monsieur gauche
gagne beaucoup d'argent c'est un qu'il
allait certainement beaucoup plus de
talent que vous et moi déjà et
deuxièmement il ya un conseil
d'administration vous savez que dans
toute société ayant consignes en
association avec les représentants du
personnel c'est pas lui qui dit tiens je
vais me prendre tant par mois par des
oui mais c'est vrai c'est pas ton sac et
le quai quels problèmes et attention on
citera que tout est sûre qu'est ce qu'il
faut faire ce qu'il faut pas s'enfermer
d'abord faire une généralité évidemment
on peut s'abriter toujours vers
l'argument de celui qui fabrique la
richesse et et kid avant le débat et
sans fin de ce côté là mais il ya
parfois juste au point par point des
comportements et des comportements qui
parfois sont
insupportables et qui pousse et qu'ils
ont tellement dans l'humiliation et je
prends un exemple qui s'est passé il ya
trois jours j'écoutais ça à la radio je
trouve ça absolument fascinant il ya un
chef d'entreprise qui a décidé
d'augmenter ses salariés d'un centime
par heure non d'un centime ça veut dire
c'est pas mal de 10 centimes par jour ça
veut dire que tu fais le compte ça fait
15 euros par an je crois la se dire que
où va-t-on non pour pousser
l'humiliation à ceux à ce stade là et
pour pas que les gens aient envie de
devenir dingue c'est ridicule on peut et
vous évoquez le fait que patrick bruel
et du talent moi je ne conteste pas nous
agirons vient non mais leur débattra
tout le monde n'est pas d'accord
avant de signer quoi que ce soit est-ce
que et patrick boos elle doit gagner de
350000 euros par an oui je pense que oui
oui et je pense quand même que patrick
et tout son talent il doit même le dire
que c'est bien de faire ça parce que
c'est bien de payer d encourager parce
que c'est important dans les hôpitaux
de
plafonner les salaires non payés les
impôts par contre oui on en paix
monsieur a payé ses impôts oui aux états
unis via l'impôt progressif
plus vous gagnez plus vous prend voilà
non mais il n'y a pas de société sans
morale et je dis que c'est immoral au
delà des arguments politiques qu'il ya
une minorité qui captent autant de
richesses quand vous avez des gens mais
de là à décider de façon organisée
habiterait que les gens doivent gagner
mais c'est la plus de 350000 euros par
an excusez moi c'est du totalitarisme
non mais attendez les règles
nécessairement il a exprimé un intérêt
général et un adhésion collective nous
c'est ce qu'on met au coeur du débat
dans la campagne qui vient ça nous
semble intéressant de parler du fait
qu'aujourd'hui le système économique
nouveau le nouvel âge du capitalisme
dans lequel sonné il fonctionne avec
cette captation des richesses par une
minorité il faudrait pas que patron
devient un gros mot
c'est important essayez vous avez
beaucoup de talent ouvrier nommé
monsieur g de crème j'étais cuisinier
serveur ambulanciers j'ai démarré je l'a
réussi dans bien des raisons quinze ans
au service l' écoute écoute j'ai
travaillé 15 ans au service des autres
et mon rêve quand j'étais dans les
wagons restaurants et que je servais
dans les wagons restaurant c'était
d'être patron je suis devenu patron vous
savez que quand vous n'êtes pas trop si
ma société se casse la gueule j'ai pas
de chômage est rien du tout je suis dans
la merde donc je prends des riches je
fais travailler du monde donc si j'ai un
peu de talent c'est un peu normal que je
gagne un peu plus comme un standardiste
qu'il ya un truc bonjour monsieur mais
je ne sais pas mais c'est combien moi
j'suis d'accord alors je vais gagner
trois cent cinquante mille euros et
aligner 30 salle attendais et je vais et
je vais et je vais donc payer 50%
d'impôts bah oui non mais c'est pas mal
déjà certains ont dit que c'est normal
que je vienne un peu plus donc on est
déjà gagné trois cent cinquante mille
euros par après lui 50% d'impôts donc je
vais gagner 175 livres mais tout le
monde va se barrer il faut le monde
qui gagnent plus de 2 des rigodons ici
oui ici non non non essayer parce que je
vous connais bien et je connais bien
monsieur mélenchon que je lui trouve un
vrai talent ma vraie valeur et ballmer
d'orateur essayer de tirer plutôt les
gens vers le haut que vers le bas
essayez de le redire entreprenez
travailler on ne se serait jamais arrêté
de travailler les patrons les patrons
les patrons oui les patrons il existe
des ouvriers existe mais j'ai toujours
respecté les gens moi j'ai fait
travailler dix mille personnes à peu
près et croyez moi j'ai vraiment magique
je vais vous dire monsieur louvain ça
peut pas être profiter tétouan je pense
que carlos ghosn par ailleurs qui
démontre pas non plus de grand talent
donc par rapport à ses résultats
économiques mais debout rigoler il croit
pas non mais vous rigolez j'espère donc
aller le fait si puisque comme il l'a
touché la 16 millions et que ça ne
choque pas mais si renault gagnent des
fortunes grâce à lui si nissan gagnent
des fortunes
c'est normal qu'ils prennent de
l'intérêt qu'ils ont nés mais il en
prend une pêcheuse en aliments aux
enfants et puis la seconde
il en prend mais vous imaginez par
rapport à ses ouvriers par rapport à ses
employés vous trouvez normal qu'ils
gagnent sept cent cinquante fois plus
que quand on baisse la rémunération du
patron le problème c'est que ça
n'entraîne pas obligatoirement la baisse
de la rémunération des autres dirigeants
par exemple des entreprises publiques le
patron peut pas gagner plus de quatre
cent cinquante mille euros sauf que dans
les entreprises publiques il ya
cinquante personnes qui gagnent plus que
le patron donc déjà baissé le salaire du
patron n'est pas obligatoirement baisser
le salaire des dirigeants ensuite est-ce
que l'état doit tout réglementer moi je
suis un partage est retiré voilà ça veut
pas dire tous pareil mais ça veut dire
quand même je vois le 21e siècle qui
souffre autant d'inégalités c'est plus
possible c'est pas possible que les 80
personnes les plus riches du monde et
possède autant que l'ensemble des
richesses de la planète l on va partager
on va organiser ça je suis en non
violent certes ça va se faire par la loi
il faut que les peuples on décide
d'accord parce que la logique de la peau
nous l'a dit c'est faire du blé données
du rendement donc c'est un problème de
fond si on casse pas ça on ne change pas
et qu'on fait pas qu on ait des
entreprises qui sont basés sur un autre
système on va détruire l'ordre devraient
quand même être d'accord parce que c'est
la forme se mettent d'accord sur un truc
le commerce on est tous d'accord la
financiarisation du monde on est moins
d'accord voilà c'est la fin merci alexis
corbière d'avoir internet
c'était la p2 de cinq ans autre
[Musique]
avant sur le terrain bonsoir taille à ce
retour s'opère toujours en compagnie de
maud fontenoy
patrick bruel gérard louvin
un actionnariat est de londres
[Applaudissements]
il eut peu
[Musique]
j'ai quand même besoin que tu nous
éclaire sur quelque chose que le
téléspectateur aussi je ne comprends pas
pour l'instant cette tradition c'est une
tradition qui sort do qui vient d'où
qu'est née comment je veux tout savoir
qu'est né un jour où j'ai revu police le
freeway que je ils font ça dans polisse
il faut savoir police cette musique te
donne envie de danser voulait pas qu'on
parle des impôts locaux
ont versé madelios aph et nab à l'urssaf
on va passer maintenant à notre tt ou de
la semaine
théo
m
les gens
gérard louvin bonsoir
on se demandait où vous étiez passé de
plaisir que vous aviez quitté touche pas
à mon poste en fait vous prépariez un
spectacle on va en parler mais d'abord
alors vous avez révélé avoir voulu
quitter touche pas à mon poste quand
cyril hanouna vous a annoncé que nabila
allait devenir chroniqueuse et vous avez
déclaré je ne tenais pas à m'asseoir à
côté d'elle c'est là on voit que vous
êtes homosexuel
wyatt quoi
les deux ans que j'ai fait je me suis
beaucoup amusé mais quand il m'a dit il
ya un habile à ça ça m'a dit je m'assois
côté de la ville on parle de télévision
au départ moi je vois pas ne voyez pas
ce qu'elle a à dire sur les médias
nabila bat pas vraiment alors c'est vrai
que depuis quelques temps il y avait de
l'eau dans le gaz vous aviez été
suspendu d'antenne pour avoir giflé un
assistant et en fait ce que cyril vous
reprocher c'est d'avoir fait ça hors
antenne
non mais un jour je raconterai
l'histoire la vraie alors après la
carrière que vous avez fait qu'un énorme
c'est vrai que c'est un peu bizarre de
voir comme ça
c'est un peu pour ça ou comme ça
là vous étiez devenu gros gégé qua non
mais là la spéciale manger nolwenn en
face de moi nolan j'ai produit quand
même cinq tournées de stars ouais et je
voyais dans son regard ouais alice est
pas lui aussi alors je les fais une fois
je les fais deux fois j'ai fait trois
fois j'ai fait quatre fois au bout d'un
moment j'ai dit j'arrête quoi je peux
pas je fais pas je me suis amusé mais
une fois de temps en temps mais non mais
je comprends très bien et c'est dans la
garde la tête que je suis et encore on
voit pas mais là tu as des douilles dans
le slip c'est derrière albert
gea ou là
pour gérard
alfred et lille lui fromont on dira un
férial killer alias géant louvain tout
commence le 5 septembre
1946 au raincy en banlieue parisienne 9
kg cette année sans vos parents tiennent
un salon de coiffure pour dames
et après la fermeture
la boutique tient lieu de salle à manger
vers l'âge de 4 ans
vous rêvez déjà gérard de spectacle fait
le show dans le cérémonie familiale
aura ainsi vous allez parler cirque
à 13 ans dans votre bain vous
interviewez vous même alors monsieur
gérard racontez-nous vos débuts
comment avez vous réussi un espace est
touchant et bigoudis en plus pour à 13
ans
à 18 ans vous travaillez dans les trains
de luxe mais les week-ends vous avez un
groupe de rock est chanteur et votre
groupe s'appelle les play-boys away
et ce qui est pourquoi vous riez
vous fait les premières parties de
jacques dutronc de michel polnareff
talida way sinon ici à l'époque mais
alors au départ en fait gérard vous y
êtes dans la lumière c'est peut-être
pour ça que vous avez fait ce jour là
mon poste je me suis réveillé je me suis
réveillé artists après j'ai vu je savais
que j'avais passé de talent et je me
suis arrivé animateurs et quand je vais
penser à faire de la télévision je
voulais présenter ma première émission
j'ai fait un essai ge était à chier donc
j'ai aussi compris que c'était prendre
mon truc donc j'invite était derrière la
caméra mais si cela se trouve en fait
cette première décision c'est à dire de
devenir un chanteur dans un groupe de
rock
c'est peut-être ce pour quoi vous étiez
fait nous vous allez tu as peur d'avoir
raté quelque chose j'étais chanteur
s'était chanteur ringard ah oui oui je
chantais en yaourt chanter un peu c'est
comme chanter les chansons del pèse pour
un flirt avec toi un peu mal ou non mais
je savais je chantais 30 à 40 chansons
par part soit puisque j'étais dans un
bal j'étais tout sauf un vrai bon
chanteur alors c'est avec tout françois
donc que vous apprendrez la direction
artistique est là et la production site
avec lui vous avez appris être odieux
avec le personnel non parce qu'ils
n'étaient pas au dieu avec le personnel
c'est là on est habillé en a pris des
trois baisses des concepts des concierge
de l'hôtel de m et derrière et on joue
au concierge on reçoit les clients c'est
un mec génial j'ai travaillé avec lui il
avait 33 ans 33 ans il était patron de
société et c'est vachement important il
avait flèche il avait absolue il avait
podium il avait tout ça et le soir
malgré tous ces soucis on lui disait
allez va chanter le lundi au soleil sais
c'est pas toujours facile alors temps en
temps a été de mauvaise humeur imaginez
que vous l'après toutes les missions
vous vous tournez vous tournez je le dis
ben part à lille tu vas faire 1h30 de
seine je suis pas sûr ensuite vous
lancerez dans le management d'artistes
donc avec elio palmade pagny j'étais
producteur de palmade j'étais producteur
kavanagh brut sur florent pagny pour le
tour michel leeb producteurs de plein de
choses grand producteur mais aussi du
mime marceau et aussi de maurice béjart
mais aussi d'alliages les textes
d'alliages été meilleurs que ceux des
mines marsaudon mais nous avons attaqué
journal en place devrait
ensuite produire des pièces douter à des
comédies musicales des émissions de
télévision dont sacrée soirée alors il
paraît que le titre de sacrés soit je
sais pas si c'est vrai mais c'est en
hommage à une partouze géante
organisée chez vous non c'est pas sympa
pour le petit garçon qu'il ya 13 heures
qu'ils la trouvaient pas ce qu'on avait
fait un concours et ment pas tu as payé
sa dette pour ça
on m'a raconté que c'est jean pierre
foucault il est là ce soir voici gens
bien foucault
mais pas là alors moi comme tous tourner
la tête trois connards contourner la
tête
alors gérard êtes ici ce soir pour audi
no qui va nouvelle production musicale à
bobino du 19 janvier au 29 avril à un
spectacle faut le dire assez étonnant
dans lequel un grand orchestre
symphonique reprend des chansons
contemporaines et là on réalise en fait
qu'avec 18 violent et 14 compet importe
quelle chanson de merde hadja galles non
mais c'est vrai 'cependant sympa pour
adèle et pour daft punk pour michel
legrand et pour edith piaf etc oui c'est
vrai
moi je veux bien que ce soit de chansons
de merde vrai c'est que des jeunes
musiciens c'est un jeune chef
d'orchestre capelle sylvain dinos qui
qu'à la passion de la musique qui fait
c'est très important qui fait partager
sa passion de la musique parle au public
sir qui fait monter des gens non
musiciens sur scène qui joue à del
il descend dans la salle pour faire des
percussions c'est une vraie expérience
musicale vous sûrs que c'est vraiment
formidable on regarde à gauche ensemble
nous dit nous
la rencontre surprenante entre des
grands thèmes populaires classiques et
des standards de la pop
[Musique]
de michael jackson à édith piaf en
passant par adele ou stravinsky
audineau transcende les genres musicaux
en toute légèreté avec une grande
liberté
[Musique]
le public partage et vit des moments
d'émotion et de surprises
[Musique]
grâce à l'interaction le public devient
lui aussi musicien et acteur de cette
soirée ludique et magique
domino du 19 janvier au 29 avril en bout
ce n'est que du bonheur c'est gentil et
on passe maintenant au bilan de la mi
temps mais le temps passe et ça s'est
passé beaucoup de choses ont changé de
firme ait pu s'imaginer de temps c'est
si vite et
patrick bruel vous êtes satisfait de la
façon dont ça s'est passé les barrages
un peu poussif un peu tendu difficile
mais je suis un peu rentré dans le jeu
voilà une chose que j'ai en deuxième mi
temps on était meilleurs sites vous
poser une question sur racines parce que
je vois vous avez beau court ainsi
d'avoir une mère enseignante fait que
coin j'ai beaucoup lu on attend
maintenant c'est plus un peu plus racine
et victor hugo que les autres peut-être
que c'est du racisme ce que je connais
du vôtre
oui on peut dire non mais c'est mon
seigneur j'ai vu la reine mais pour le
faire voir j'en ai peur c'est qu'à peine
les flots tout son nouveau d'un peuple
adorateurs khatir sur ses pas
s'approcher à grandeur
bérénice mathieu quel bilan jusqu'à
présent que marie thérèse mathieu ouais
euh pardon excusez moi je pense que ma
carrière d'écrivain est bien lancée
grâce à toi voilà non mais c'est vrai
que quand gg baffie là je regardais
vieux sergio leone je sais et j'ai
l'impression d'être le mec qui va se
faire tuer à dire mais [ __ ] merde il a
fait avant merde et un jour je me faire
tirer dans le dos way et compte sur moi
moi de l'esca des choses dont c'étaient
des gens pas vous n'êtes pas encore
passé et je vous êtes inquiète de ce qui
vous attend que ça s'arrête alors
qu'elle parle je pourrais peut-être
amené le monsieur porte-parole de
mélenchon qui parlait beaucoup du goût
de l'effort ramé avec moi cinq mois
c'est le bilan on pense maintenant à
notre invité politique de la semaine
maud fontenoy bonsoir
publier ses plans des tempêtes j'en ai
vu d'autres et vous écrivez en à peine
24 heures je suis passé de la gentille
navigatrice nommé personnalité de
l'année par time magazine
à la mi chambre de droite alors on va
commencer bien sûr par la gentille
navigatrice
tu es le plus mon époque
alors page 60 vous dit j'avais le mal de
mer j'avais peur de la solitude je
craignais de ne pas y arriver par moi
même et je décidé donc de partir sur les
océans en solitaire et sans assistance
qu'est ce qui vous a pris c'est vrai que
je voulais aller à contre-courant et
aller contre
ce qu'ils peuvent être les fragilités
des humains j'ai choisi de partir à la
rame dans des aventures des premières
féminines et dans des aventures pas
gagné d'avancé pour montrer que l'homme
était capable de réaliser des rêves plus
grand que lui pour montrer qu'avec de la
volonté de la persévérance du travail de
la détermination on arrivait à tous même
quelque chose qui peut paraître aussi
insensé qu'un tout petit bateau de ram
une blonde et hameaux ses envies
dantesques et j'avais envie de prouver
que finalement c'était notre étincelle
de vie notre énergie notre goût de
l'effort notre notre soif d'aventuré
notre capacité à nous relever dans les
difficultés qui faisait que finalement
même aussi grand qu'ils puissent être
cet océan on le traverse est d'abord
qudra après-coup drame et que c'était
comme une immense montagne comme on dit
à l'éléphant se mange petite cuillère
voilà en 2003 je peux être la traversée
est pendante est sûre de t'accompagner
[Rires]
qui protège te protège un sais c'est que
de l'amitié alors vous me dites moi j'ai
traversée de l'atlantique nord à la 117
jours
6700 kilomètres seul sans assistance et
25 ans en 2005 c'est l'océan pacifique
que vous traversez 73 jours 7000
kilomètres seul et sans assistance
et en 2007 c'est le tour du monde à la
voile à contre courant
150 jours
47 millions
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est un gentil
navigatrice
mais deux ans
et en plus pendant ce temps là donc sur
la mer vous avez tenu à rester féminine
vous vous et pilier les jambes on sait
jamais toi un cargo qui passe pour être
présentable devoir
vous mettiez des crèmes anti rides mais
c'est vachement bien et il faut quand
même se laver les cheveux à -5 dans un
seau d'eau glacée quand même un mot de
la fée et boire son urine quand le
dessalinisateur est en panne c'est moins
excitant de coulage
alors au goring c'est
le pire dans ce que vous dites quand
même de terry c'est quand on est tout
seul en mer avec le bateau là on a peur
de mourir non mais ces aventures cette
aventure incroyable parce qu'à la fois
se sentir tout seul tout petit humanoïde
en train de traverser cet océan immense
quand on regarde sa position sur la
carte et avec des fois je bougeais
absolument pas oui et je vais de temps
en temps la terre au téléphone et qui
était en l'occurrence maman parce que
j'avais pas vraiment de tessé à terre
qui me disait tu alors tu viens d'où non
heureusement encore paramé et c'est vrai
qu'il m'arrivait souvent de reculer il
faut le giro chimot de l'absence de de
spectateurs pour vous applaudir non ça
personne ne vous dira pas si c'est bien
vous êtes tout seul quoi alors c'est
vrai que vous avez tous vu le film seul
au monde et on a tendance à se parler un
peu pour s'encourager moi j'étais suivie
par des milliers d'enfants et notamment
par beaucoup d'enfants malades dans les
hôpitaux en oncologie pédiatrique donc
j'avais envie de leur prouver que
c'était possible j'ai toujours eu des
programmes éducatifs et j'ai ma
fondation depuis 15 ans qui a été
soutenu par par de nombreuses
personnalités patrick a été quelqu'un de
très généreux il faut dire que delà de
la grande carrière de patrick c'est
aussi quelqu'un qui s'engage qui
s'engagent pour venir avec moi parler
auprès de milliers d'enfants qui ont à
travers ces mots envie aussi de rêver
sur un avenir dans l'avenir possible
[Applaudissements]
on arrêtera très partie
si je teins
bon alors là voilà vous rencontrer
nicolas sarkozy
vous allez à l'elysée il vous élève au
rang de chevalier de l'ordre national du
mérite et il en profite pour vous
touchez une mission
commando
ans il est resté très proche mais
finirait par rejoindre les républicains
et c'est là que la gentille navigatrice
devient la méchante de droite
[Musique]
aujourd'hui vous êtes délégué à
l'environnement du parti républicain
viet vice-présidente de la région paca
chargé du développement durable et vous
écrivez dans valeurs actuelles
gratuitement je le précise et là vous
découvrez que les tempêtes politiques
sont plus violentes que celles que vous
avez connues en mer vous appelez vos
adversaires les khmers verts
faut dire quand même que pendant les
primaires de la droite nicolas sarkozy
est déclarée
l'environnement ça commence à bien faire
c'est vrai que les a pas aidés juste
pour repréciser un petit peu je soutiens
nicolas sarkozy parce qu'on a une
histoire commune
j'ai un enfant qui a souffert d'une très
très grave maladie et c'est grâce à
nicolas qu'on a pu pour suivre des
traitements et qu'aujourd'hui il est
encore là la deuxième chose c'est
pourquoi je me suis engagé c'était lui
mais c'était surtout le sujet c'est à
dire faire comprendre que
l'environnement c'est primordial pour
l'avenir de chacun d'entre nous quand il
déclare il faut être arrogant comme
l'homme pour penser que c'est nous qui
changeront le climat c'est sympa du vous
aider ça le climat est en train de
changer comme le climat a beaucoup
changé tout au long des siècles et des
siècles il ya une grande période de
sécheresse des grandes périodes d'eau de
froid de il ya toujours eu des grandes
périodes de changement et la
biodiversité à une certaine époque après
deux disparus de près de 80 90 % et
cette biodiversité là elle elle est
revenue la seule chose qui change
aujourd'hui c'est qu'aujourd'hui on a
des activités humaines qui crée des
pollutions on a du mal à gérer et c'est
quoi la question c'est pas tant la
question du réchauffement quoi c'est la
question de savoir est ce que l'homme va
être capable de survivre cette toute
petite planète qu'aujourd'hui on
surconsomme alors qu'on va devenir
bientôt 9 milliards donc les grands
problèmes c'est quoi c'est qu'elles sont
les accès au transport les commandes à
traiter nos déchets qu'elles vont être
une moyenne de production comment on va
survivre au niveau alimentaire et c'est
toutes ces grandes questions qui sont
prêts mental pas seulement celle de
savoir s'il ya eu ou pas dans les
siècles des changements climatiques dont
l'aimé toujours
nicolas
m
le programme écologique de nicolas
sarkozy c'était de [ __ ] alain juppé
dans un composteur en fait c'était sa
seule idée alors c'est pas facile d'être
écologiste de droite c'est quoi c'est
dire si les pandas disparaissent c'est
un peu de leur faute ils avaient qu'à se
bouger le cul
alors vous dit un truc d'invoquer
vouloir faire rimer économie et écologie
mais sarine déjà mais
ce que j'essaye de dire c'est que le coc
logis aujourd'hui ça peut être une
écologie positive ça peut être une
écologie réalisme écologie pragmatique
et qu'aujourd'hui cette écologie las ça
doit pas être toujours d'essayer de
faire un peu moins ou de culpabiliser
l'homme dans son souci de consommer avec
un discours qui est toujours le c'était
mieux avant ce côté arrière-garde et
retour en arrière moi ne convient pas et
je trouve hors de propos quand tu pense
qu'aujourd'hui encore un enfant qui
meurt de faim toutes les cinq secondes
dans le monde alors qu'est ce qu'on veut
comme monde pour demain mais demain il
va falloir produire différemment et pas
juste un peu moins complètement
différemment et différemment ça veut
dire comprendre que la nature c'est une
source de solutions et c'est une source
de richesse on comprend la prolifération
des cellules cancérigènes grâce à
l'étoile de mer on traite aujourd'hui le
sida grâce à l'aise et et qui vient du
hareng on comprend on travaille sur le
nerf optique humain grâce au nerf
optique à la marque est 1000 fois
supérieur au nôtre aujourd'hui on est en
train de travailler sur l'alzheimer
grâce à la méduse il ya un potentiel
incroyable
dernière question dont vous ne tapez
région paca donc un responsable du
développement durable c'est plus dur de
passer le cap horn ou de rire à une
blague d'eric ciotti
[Rires]
certain c'est que c'est plus dur
je me suis jamais senti aussi seul en
politique malgré mes aventures de mois
et de mois et deux semaines de nos
semaines sur notre bateau absolument
c'est un compliment
tu es le plus beau des morts
voilà c'était la pétoire des celtes et
on se retrouve sur terre
avec guillon 2007 l autre
même en son sein
oui
volent dans les airs comme de choc des
héros
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ramon soir les tailleurs sont bons choix
les terriens nous sommes de retour sur
terre toujours en cours baby de notre
emploi
et patrick bruel
talent de vie
et maintenant c'est l'heure de guillon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quelques anguilles en bonsoir bonsoir
thierry ardisson qu'est-ce qui se passe
tout va bien bon on y va oui politique
qu'on démarre avec la primaire de la
gauche
cette semaine on est obligé n'en parle
un bien son jeu s'emmerde tout le monde
mais là on est à huit jours du scrutin
donc on en parle primaires de la gauche
alors qu emmanuel macron ont rempli des
salles de 8000 places manuel valls a
rassemblé 200 personnes à liévin
souhaitons un manuel de faire mieux que
le score de jean françois copé à la
primaire de la droite 0,3 pour cent
c'était son père sa mère ses cousins et
ses cousines si la famille de valser
plus nombreuses que celles de copé il
devrait s'en sortir
déclarations de manuel valls à la une du
parisien je ne crois pas être favori
tant mieux tant mieux ça tombe bien tant
mieux
les mauvaises nouvelles s'accumulent
pour l'ancien premier ministre selon un
sondage de la sofres val serait battu
par montebourg au second tour de la
primaire de la gauche de son côté le
chantre du made in france s'est déclaré
sûr de sa victoire je vais l'échiné
thierry ardison le black bull et les
tourbières et le châtier
haro sur les faits l'eau les rennais gaz
et les judas quand on a trahi les
valeurs de la gauche
imposée le 49-3 on ne revient pas la
mine enfarinée jouer les pompiers
pyromanes on ne revient pas interdit
si vis pacem para bellum
les français ne seront pas à nouveau
gros jean comme devant sus à l'infâme
manuel carlos ghosn il faut l'occire le
disent faire c'est façon puzzle s'il
aime tant les charters qu'il retourne en
espagne
[Applaudissements]
déclaration de françois kalfon directeur
de campagne de montebourg macron c'est
pierrette le poteau mais il veut tout
souvent qui trop embrasse mal étreint il
ya quelqu'un dans l'équipe de montebourg
qui parlent français normalement
un français que tout le monde comprend
alors c'est une exclusivité on vient à
l'instant de recevoir la musique
d'entrée des milk team d'arnaud
montebourg
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
salut
à la proche de la primaire de la gauche
jean christophe cambadélis a organisé
une simulation de vote
la nasa parfois fait des simulations sur
des missions très compliqué airbus
industrie la formule 1 mais organisé une
simulation pour glisser un bulletin dans
une urne
il va nous manquer cambadélis il va nous
manquer
voilà mitterrand disait je crois aux
forces de l'esprit faut qu'ils
reviennent la vitalité on passe à une
nouvelle séquence le bon plan de la
semaine
comment comment ne plus payer la maison
de retraite de ses parents une charge
souvent très lourdes pour les familles
environ 3000 euros par mois et bien
aujourd'hui je vous recommande la maison
de retraite korian berthelot à lyon 13
personnes y sont mortes en quinze jours
un record si vous souhaitez y placer vos
parents écrivez leur durée moyenne d'un
séjour entre trois et six semaines
maximum
ça fait quand même une sacrée économie
c'était le bon plan le masque
valérie pécresse souhaite la fin de la
gratuité des transports publics en ile
de france en cas de pic de pollution
bah oui oui ça coûte trop cher ça coûte
trop cher 4 millions d'euros par jour on
peut plus on peut plus donc respirer des
particules fines et faites vous un
cancer des poumons ça s'est pris en
charge mais attention jusqu'en mai 2017
ap si fillon passé finit plus de sécu
donc on profite on profite maintenant
48 mille morts par an en france dus à la
pollution urbaine je ne veux pas un qui
était pécresse mais ça fait quand même
48000 pass navigo en moi
faut bien réfléchir faire les comptes
qu'est-ce qui est le plus avantageux à
vos calculettes
[Applaudissements]
deux sénateurs saisissent le csa après
le passage de farid benyettou dans salut
les terriens durant son interview l'ex
mentor des frères coen si les assassins
de charlie hebdo a brandi un pin's je
suis charlie les sénateurs dénoncent une
scène d'une rare indécence notre
programmatrice à salut les terriens
allait mal à katie katie elle est mal
ouais c'est katie t'a vu ces connards de
sénateurs franchement 1 ils ont que ça à
[ __ ] un farid benyettou c'est pas lui
qui a tiré sur les journalistes de
charlie il les a conseillés motivé mais
c'est pas lui c'est chiant cette
histoire ben on est emmerdé thierry non
parce qu on pensait faire un duplex avec
sale abdeslam le terroriste du bataclan
dans sa cellule de fleury mérogis il
sait qu'ils regrettent salah ouais ouais
regrette badens tout terroriste il ya un
coeur qui bat ou ou le coup thierry
pensais que ce serait pas mal qui porte
un tee shirt je suis bataclan toi le
côté rénovation ouais et pour
l'anniversaire de l'attentât de nice
ouais c'est loin mais je t'en parle on
éviterait volontiers ramzy rfa le
complice du chauffeur du camion ouais
ouais l'eau ou à lui aussi regrette qui
regrette et si l'émission est en plein
air thierry pensait un feu d'artifice
avec des coeurs en hommage aux victimes
mais il faut que ce soit bon goût ouais
nan thierry le bon goût il y tient
bisous bisous bisous
[Applaudissements]
bon je me disais thierry la saison
prochaine pour notre émission de rentrée
invité le fils ben laden une spéciale 11
septembre pour la petite touche humour
en plateau on invite aussi charlélie
couture pour chanter comme un avion sans
aile 1 j'en parle à cathy
[Musique]
bernard arnault propriétaire du groupe
lvmh premier français à serrer la pince
de donald trump embrassades accolades et
compliments à gogo entre les deux hommes
ah oui oui quand on possède dior vuitton
givenchy guerlain quand on symbolise
l'élégance et la distinction à travers
le monde il est important de s'afficher
rapidement avec un homme qui préconise
d'attraper les femmes par la chatte
trump j'adore
pas je me fâche avec tous les gros que
chef d'entreprise soupire ah ouais c'est
chiant quand même pas si je me fâche
avec bolloré avec arme au pineau tu vas
pas après je
sais pas qu'est ce que je deviens et
reste hanouna
nicolas sarkozy surpris par un policier
alors qu'il faisait du vélo en sens
interdit sur le port de saint-tropez
l'officier de police lui a demandé de
descendre et de continuer à pied
franchement thierry ardisson c'est de
l'acharnement
à l'heure j'ai en vacances en famille
que je suis plus candidat à la
présidentielle on vient m'arrêter me
demander de descendre avec un peu de
chance on va me demander la facture du
vélo avec quel argent je les achetais
10000euros lé cadre en carbone c'est
martine aubry qui me l'a offert un c'est
pas la vie bettencourt sais pas monsieur
takieddine c'est martin on va aussi
contre les mesures il me faire pisser
dans un bocal me déclaré positif sous
prétexte que j'ai mis 10 minutes pour
relier le cap [ __ ] à saint tropez j'ai
triché je suis le lance amstrong de la
politique comme le laisse faire du vélo
thierry ardisson comme n'importe quel
retraités faire des mots fléchés et
relire la princesse de clèves je n'en
demande pas plus à l'espagne
c'est là
charles la mer cimer était avec nous
le 19 janvier à bobino rue de la gaîté
jusqu'au 29 avril et maintenant nous
passons à noter rien du samedi soir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors qu'évêques et 20 ans fred fut jean
fred et moi c'est déjà si réglé alors
grâce à une aile rigide
équipé de quatre mini-réacteurs
posé sur le dos vous réaliser le rêve de
tout homme sur terre voler comme un
oiseau
on vous appelle les jets semaine et vous
êtes les premiers hommes volants de
d'histoire et pour la première fois vous
exprimer sur un plateau c'est celui de
salut hitlérien merci fin
[Musique]
frag vous êtes né le 25 juillet 1979 et
si votre père était parachutiste décès
votre mère secrétaire médicale et vous
avez huit jours quand vos parents vous
font découvrir le club de parachutisme
d'annecy et du fond de votre landau vous
regardez votre père sauter voilà vous
ferez votre premier saut avec votre papa
à l'âge de dix ans et tout seul à l'âge
de 16 ans vince vous êtes né le 15
septembre 1984 à m6 père moniteur de
parachutisme mère dans l'informatique à
la différence de fred
la chute libre c'est pas vraiment
d'autres trucs voulait être peinard vous
aimez plutôt le judo en fait voilà et
c'est à 14 ans que vous sautez pour la
première fois avec votre père pour qu'il
arrête de vous saouler avec ce à quoi ou
qui vous lâche mais ça vous colle le
virus et donc vous faites votre premier
solo à l'âge de 15 ans voilà après le
bac fred entame un bts d'action
commerciale
c'était un échec un échec total et vous
vince un crp de charpentier échec total
ça vous gardent tous les deux voilà et
vous vous rencontrez au club de
parachutisme d'annecy et vous commencez
à sauter ensemble en 2000 vous faites du
free fly alors le free fly c'est un truc
incroyable et elle va un maximum de deux
figures avant le déclenchement du
parachute voile à partir de là vous
intégrez l'équipe de france et vous ne
perdrez plus jamais une seule
compétition vous serez trois fois
champion du monde
en 2012 après sept mille sauts vous
parvenez à voler avec une précision
millimétrique
votre spécialité c'est le tête contre
tête à 300 km heure vos vidéos sont
visionnées des millions de fois sur
internet et en 2012 à chicago
138 pas sudiste saute en se donnant la
main gang bang aérien on regarde à quoi
ça ressemble
[Musique]
à un rêve
anna rabbits au départ
elle agit tout fait de la peine
vincent
duguet dance qui est
incroyable c'est magique ne se retrouver
à 300 km heure avec autant de personnes
c'est cet homme a été dans des secteurs
un peu différent moi j'étais au centre
il était un peu plus à l'extérieur et
quand c'est la fin du trias vous
dessinez la rosace avant vous met en
scène nous préparer il s'appelle est
bien mal à vous rencontrer dans le ciel
et blanc avec les paroles et vous
inquiétez pas c'est en fait il ya des
marques dans deux personnes en ciel et
puis en groupe 1 où vient ce besoin mais
qui ont créé la formation et puis à part
tout seul et on répète les sauts jusqu'à
ce que la figure soit réalisé combien de
rater oui c'est ça on a fait une
quinzaine d'essais avant de faire leurs
gammes morts 1000 morts
il ya des pickpockets ou pas
parallèlement depuis le début des années
2000 vous pratiquez le baise japarov
j'explique ce que c'est sauter à partir
d'un point fixe signé parce que ce soit
un immeuble une antenne une falaise où
un pont watts à bourem est le problème
le problème du destin parfaite c'est
qu'au début il n'y a pas d'air on tombe
comme une pierre c'est ça c'est ça qui
est compliqué c'est ça qui est bon aussi
en fait un le
vraiment le départ à vitesse 0 c'est
sympa et puis à un moment il faut
accepter la chute et jusqu'à ce qu'on
ait suffisamment d'appuis sur l'air pour
pouvoir commencer à se déplacer mike
brant a essayé live band s'est planté la
belle à la portance d'invendus a causé
par le problème c'est que c'est illégal
c'est illégal à certains endroits comme
j'ai fait le viaduc de millau par
exemple 300 m c'était illégal non mais
c'est vrai que vous avez peur des flics
et et que cette peur peut altérer votre
concentration bah ouais en fait on n'a
jamais été vraiment trop adepte des
sceaux illégaux même si on en a fait
quelques-uns à paris notamment et mon le
viaduc de millau c'est un peu un
classique mais la plupart du temps on
saute de montagne et la plupart des
spots en montagne en france en tout cas
et en europe en général sont les goûts
on regarde maintenant le saut de
basejump le plus haut jamais réalisé
c'est la tour burj khalifa
828 mètres donc à dubaï on regarde à
quoi ça phong
[Musique]
le mec
servant également pendant combien de
temps donc vous tombé comme une pierre
bah ça dépend quand on a fait le saut
tête en bas c'est par une quinzaine de
secondes et quand on fait le tour de la
tour c'était après 45 3 39 40 secondes
mais le truc génial dans tout ça c'est
que on nous a donné l'autorisation de
saut 17 tours et on nous a construit une
plateforme à 828 mètres pour qu'on
puisse va réaliser un rêve voir que
quand vous dire que le jour on veut
faire ça de la tour eiffel bomba appel
on a demandé l'idée ça va être compliqué
fini en prison
en mai 2014 vous sautez de 10000 mètres
au dessus du mont blanc c'est historique
à 1 an et demi de préparation avec le
problème de l'oxygène parce que à 10000
mètres évidemment il ya moins d'oxygène
le trafic aérien si vous avez peur de
prendre un avion la gueule parce que le
monde pleure pas si la gueule de pilotes
c'est très proche de l'aéroport de
genève cointrin et le 31 mai 2014 à 15
heures vous avez enfin l'autorisation
vous avez 10 minutes devant vous
le vol va durer sept minutes
[Musique]
incroyable aussi au niveau changements
de température parce que là où il fait
moins 50 et ambac g20 devraient quoi le
temps de retirer ton pull tu te prends
les films ces quatre minutes j'avais su
70 degrés d'écart et là que j'allais
devenir des diètes mène alors elle qui
vous permet d'être des jazzmen a été
inventé au début des années 2000 par un
suisse s'appelle yves rossy ancien
pilote de chasse dans ces tunnels rigide
qui se porte comme un sac à dos avec
quatre petits moteurs à réaction mais ça
pèse 70 kg ha bah c'est sûr que c'était
assez dur en fait la première fois qu'il
m'a contacté il me dire ça te branche
sera d'essayer c'est elle moi j'avais 25
ans j'avais dix mille sources me suis
dit ça doit pas être compliqué son truc
et il ment mais dans son hangar et me
dit tu veux essayer la mettre sur ton
dos tu pas de problème et au moment où
je la mets son dos et je marnach je me
lève je fais quelques pas et c'était
tellement lourd nous suivons mais ça
c'est certain pour moi c'est pas pour
moi tout de suite quand il m'a fallu
quasiment six mois avant de commencer la
formation ils avouent leurs contacts et
effectivement et là c'est le miracle
[Musique]
et
on regarde
[Musique]
excellent c'est la science fiction
là on est à l'horizontale on a à peu
près 1
280 300 km/heure et on peut aller
jusqu'à 350 km l'autonomie c'est quoi
dix minutes mais c'est surtout que quand
tu es enfant et que et que tu fais
l'avion comme regard mais la musique là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
je crois que
non ce qu'il faut dire c'est quand on a
ça dans le dos on utilise ses épaules
pour tourner on utilise sa tête pour
monter ou pour ceux d'essence n'existera
si je veux descendre je pousse sur les
bus montée je tire le guern as tu vois
dans le cul infos précises et c est le
corps et le fuselage donc et le corps
fait fuselage donc il est il est mobile
et c'est pour ça qu'on peut réaliser
toutes ses acrobaties et c'est une
invention merveilleux avons la chance de
pouvoir voler ça et c'est un métier où
on lève le matin et on va voler qu'est
ce que vous faites en vacances parce que
l'exploit suivant c'est un vol en tandem
avec un airbus
a380 on regarde
[Musique]
e
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bravo
[Applaudissements]
départs conjoints
quelques mètres veut voir les perses les
quelques personnes à l'intérieur on
pouvait les voir demain quand on était
au bout du oui il est comme j'imagine
pouvez voir les personnes atteintes
d'arthrite s'estime à j 2 au 25 je suis
arrivé deux mecs par les bleus et puis
il ya le vol en formation avec la
patrouille de france et là franchement
ça n'est jamais en fait c'est à couper
le souffle
regardez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors
[Musique]
bien département pas de quoi que ce soit
qu'est-ce qui est ce qui se passe je ne
sais qu il ya on est deuxième à la base
on
reste quand même un truc ses records de
felix baumgartner 36 mm quand même quoi
tu as on aimerait bien monter à 36 mm
avec ses ailes avec les réacteurs quoi
seriez alors une dizaine de sullens bon
il ya plein de il ya plein de choses qui
sont en préparation va vers est un peu
dans le futur
[Musique]
les copains
bravo à l'ofce très bon livre aux fans
on venait qu'on voulait vous êtes nos
idoles
[Applaudissements]
le 18 janvier à 20h50 canal+ diffuse
pornocratie les nouvelles multi
nationales du sexe un documentaire écrit
et réalisé par ovidy on regarde à quoi
ça ressemble
l'industrie pornographique un monde en
mutation ou en perdition
ces sites proposent à des mineurs
potentiellement de regarder du contenu
adulte
c'est marrant parce que ça ressemble pas
du tout à une entreprise pour adultes la
nuit non nous pourrions être une belle
aux vies dit vous dévoile le côté obscur
du business du x est-ce que les
pratiques aussi ont changé oh oui c'est
devenu plus brutale les gens sont
devenus fous bien plus fort qu'avant
voire
ovidie mantois alors si quelqu'un est
bien placé pour parler de l'industrie du
porno c'est vous d'abord vous était
actrice de film hard et depuis 17 ans
vous réalisez des films x féministe vous
dites que le milieu du x est mal en
point les actrices sont obligés de
tourner des scènes de plus en plus hard
pour deux fois moins d'argent il ya un
grand paradoxe
on n'a jamais autant consommé de porno
que qu'à l'heure actuelle on est à plus
de 100 milliards de vidéos visionnées
chaque année sur des sites ils sont
construits sur le même le même modèle
que youtube en fait mais version
pornographique donc des sites de
streaming et pourtant 70% de la
production pornographique a disparu
pourquoi parce que l'origine ce
bouleversement il ya les plateformes
mais ils pillent tout en fait ils ont
mis en place une stratégie qui était
assez maligne c'est à dire ils ont fait
fortune à partir du du piratage à partir
du moment où ils ont saigné à blanc
toute cette industrie dans le monde
entier soit aux états unis en europe ils
ont racheté les boîtes qui était
moribonde et ils ont étendu à un
monopole sur l'ensemble de cette
industrie ce qui est assez intéressant
de constater c'est que finalement il se
passe tant mieux depuis que c'est
exactement la même chose que dans tout
le reste du marché du travail
c'est-à-dire une numérisation à l'heure
actuelle ceux qui sont à la tête du
milieu du xx e sont pas les producteurs
à l'ancienne se sont pas les gens qui
ont baigné dans cette industrie ce sont
des geeks et des experts elle s'appelle
fabián thilleman donc et sans groupe
s'appelle manwin
35 sociétés donc avec à un montage assez
assez opaque et peut-être que ce fabien
kidman n'est qu'un prête-nom pour des
financiers en fait on sait pas très bien
on ne sait pas au final qui financent
tous ces groupes là donc il ya quelque
chose qui est assez étrange fabien
thilleman effectivement c'est moi j'ai
entendu parler lui pour la première fois
en décembre 2012 quand il a été arrêté à
son domicile
à bruxelles et la presse à ce moment-là
a titré le roi du porno vient d'être est
sous les verrous et je me suis dit mais
mais c'est qui ce mec est en fait en
faisant cette enquête je me suis rendu
compte qu'en l'espace de seulement trois
ans il avait à lui tout seul bouleversé
toute cette industrie est créée la
première multinationale du x c'est
normal que ce n'est aps la soie autres
ou
shangai chez orange
et pire c'est qu'il n'y ait même pas ces
sociétés sont domiciliés à chypre au
luxembourg en irlande dans le de
labouheyre c'est ce que votre
commentaire essaye d'éclaircir c'est
tout à fait intéressant donc ça
s'appelle pornocratie si
c'était hier
du soleil
monde
patrick
gérard 1
monsieur
merci à tous ceux qui n'ont pas cette
édition on est ici reste en prison
versailles d'ici là sur ces mythes wever
au revoir l'émission sa lucarne
[Musique]
non
les corrections de ne rien rater de in a
l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux